kate beckinsale alleges Harvey Weinstein
sexually harassed her as a teenager on
Thursday morning the 44 year old posted
a photo to Instagram of herself at a
younger age claiming in the caption that
the embattled movie mogul had called her
to a meeting in his hotel room when she
was 17 years old quote he opened the
door in his bathrobe it did not cross my
mind that this older unattractive man
would expect me to have any sexual
interest in him the underworld star
added that she left the alleged meeting
feeling quote uneasy but unscathed
she then claims that a few years later
Weinstein asked her if he had tried
anything with her in that first meeting
quote I realized he couldn't remember if
he had assaulted me or not
Beckinsale is the latest in a string of
Hollywood actresses alleging that
Weinstein had sexually harassed them
following the New York Times initial
article last Thursday which accused the
producer of sexual misconduct dating
back three decades in a statement to et
Weinstein's lawyer Charles J harder
called the New York Times report quote
saturated with false and defamatory
statements on Tuesday it was reported
that Weinstein was planning on leaving
the country to seek treatment for sex
addiction but a source told ET on
Wednesday that the film producer flew to
Arizona instead at the advice of his
brother Bob adding that there is a
continuing discussion within Weinstein's
team about where he will officially
receive his treatment
then on Thursday London's Metropolitan
Police told ET they have opened an
investigation based on an allegation of
sexual assault by Weinstein that was
reported on Wednesday the NYPD also
confirmed to ET that they are conducting
a review to determine if there are any
additional complaints
[Music]